hello
we're going to talk about secret sharing
slice formulas and monotone wheel
circuits
and this is a joint work with benny
applebaum amus weimail myself
nadi peter and tony pitassi as a part of
the itcs conference
and throughout the talk we are mainly
going to discuss three models
the first one will be secret sharing
schemes which is an information
theoretic cryptographic
model and the other two will be types of
formulas or circuits
that have special gates in them
that will be either slice gates or
monotone real gates
we'll define everything throughout the
talk
and
the middle model here the formulas of
our slice gates is a new model which we
introduced to connect between the secret
sharing schemes and the monotone wheel
gates
so our goal
will be to
obtain new lower bounds for recent
techniques in secret sharing
in the past few years there have been
breakthroughs in the world of secret
sharing
and we would like to show that there is
a limit on how much you can improve
secret sharing schemes
without introducing even more new ideas
the way to do it
will be
to show lower bounds for a specific
family of
monotone wheel circuits
and to show that they also apply to
formulas over slice gates and then to
secret sharing schemes
with recent techniques
so we will do this by showing
transformations from secret sharing to
formulas over slices and then to
circuits over real gates
and on the way we'll get a new upper
bounds so we'll be able to take the
recent years upper bounds for secret
sharing
and show that they also apply to
formulas over slices and we'll get
the first non-trivial upper bounds for
monotone real circuits as well
so we'll first introduce secret sharing
schemes
so
in this protocol we'll have a dealer
which is randomized and it holds a
secret s
and it wants to share it to end parties
and by sharing we mean that it sends one
message
to every party
and we want the messages to follow
these properties
the first one is that
every authorized coalition
of
parties
will be able to recover the secret
and we define this list of authorized
coalitions in
advance and we would like that every
unauthorized coalition of parties will
learn nothing about the secret
information theoretically
so we will call this list of authorized
coalitions the access structure
that we want to deal the secret to
and we notice that every access
structure actually corresponds to a
function
that gives the grade one to all
authorized sets and the grade 0 to all
unauthorized sets
so we'll be able to say that we want to
share the secret according to some
boolean function
and that function will be monotone
why is that if we have a specific subset
that can recover the secret in this
example it's uh
the parties one two and three
and then of course that if we add
another party party six here
the four of them together will be able
to recover the secret they just need to
run their reconstruction algorithm
with the shares of parties one two and
three and just ignore the share of uh
party number six so this is what we mean
by monotone
and now we will talk about a basic
property of secret sharing which
connects it to monotone formulas
as we said before we would later want to
connect secret sharing to
formulas with special gates so this is
the first step
and this property will be closure over
or or and gates
and by that we mean that if it is easy
to share the secret according to two
functions
f1 and f2
then it will also be easy to share it
according to their disjunction or to
their conjunction
so first the case
of or gates
if we want to share the secret s
according to f we can simply share it
twice
once according to f1 and once according
to f2
and then if a party is authorized
if a coalition sorry is authorized by
either
f1
or f2 then this coalition of parties
will be able to recover the secret which
is exactly the behavior that we want
from an or gate
and with an n-gate it's not much harder
if we want to show the secret we will
share a random secret r according to f1
and the secret rx or s according to f2
and then only if a coalition is
authorized by both f1 and f2
it will be able to recover the secret s
and in both cases the share size
of f will be equal to the share size
of the
sharing that we did according to f1 plus
the share size of f2
and the share sizes will be the
important measure of complexity for us
for secret
and we will define this complexity as
the minimal total length of
all share sizes among all schemes that
realize
f
so just a few examples
the secret sharing of uh n out of n
access structure where the only
authorized coalition is all n parties
that
can be done
with the total share size of n bits
we also know that the
access structure which is a bit more
complicated which is a threshold access
structure
where coalitions of size t are
authorized
that takes a bit more
and log n bits and that is the
threshold the secret sharing schemes
that's the most common and well-known
access structure that secret sharing
schemes are used for
and this
originated this field by shamira at 79
and
if we deal with general functions
then by the previous slide
we know that we can have a secret
sharing schemes with total share size
which equals the formula size of f
but that is very large
2 to the n
and it is a big open problem
in the field of information theoretic
cryptography
whether
we can do better than that or more
generally what is the complexity of
general access structures
so 2 to the n was known since the work
of ito analy in
1987 and it took over 30 years until the
big breakthrough by levi kutanatan and
we
to get to an exponent below one of 0.994
and since then
we have managed together with say upper
bound by middle of harassing peter
in a line of work to get exponents all
the way down to 0.585 or
one and a half to the n
but the thing is that the lower bound is
still
not even quadratic it's really far below
the upper bounds and a natural question
to ask is can the recent techniques
achieve sub-exponential complexity that
means 2 to the n to the epsilon for some
epsilon
and the main result of this uh work
is that there exists a function in
monotony p for which the recent
techniques cannot get us
to sub-exponential complexity and we get
stuck at two to the
n
over
log squared of n
and
our first step towards this main result
will be the connection
we talked about between secret sharing
and slice functions
so slice functions are functions that
are basically only interesting when
their inputs are
are of hamming weight exactly k
for lighter inputs they will always
output zero and for heavier ones they
will always output one
we can see this here graphically
and formally a kl slice has l input bits
and it is only unconstrained when the
hamming weight of the input is of size
exactly k
so
formulas over slices
are monotone formulas where each gate
can compute some kl slice
and the weight k and the fan in l
can vary between the different gates and
they also can be unbounded so this seems
like a powerful model
and
and then or gates are also slice
functions
or gate is a one out of two slice and
end is two out of two slice gate
so every monotone function has an fos of
size two to the n as monotone formulas
do
and the question is can we do better
with this model can these very powerful
slice slices
very powerful gates allow us to
build smaller formulas for every
function
and the answer is yes and we reach this
conclusion via the connection between
formulas over slices and secret sharing
and the key observation which allows us
to do this is that recent sql sharing
schemes
were all based on formulas over slices
and in more detail
all schemes had the following common
steps so first we implicitly construct
the constant depth formula over slices
for general function f
and then we realize each gate cheaply
with a secret sharing scheme so
apparently
slices
can also be
cheaply implemented for secret sharing
since the work of lvw
and then we derive a secret sharing
schemes via composition over end and or
gate similar to what we've seen a couple
of slides ago
so
the color corollary of this
is that
just like secret chain schemes every
function
can be computed by formula over sizes
with the same complexity of
three halves to the n
and which is very nice
and we must say that um the
this observation is not completely
obvious for some of the works and it
took some work to understand that there
is in fact implicitly a constant depth
uh
fos built in these secret sharing
schemes
so moving on
and we do a recap to our general plan
we now
talked about the connection between
secret sharing schemes and formulas over
slices and we would like to talk about
the next connection to
monitor unreal circuits and get closer
to our lower bound
so to do so we first define this
computational model by putlak from 97
and here we will have circuits and
formulas with special gates that take as
inputs two real values and output a real
value
and it is crucial that these gates will
be monotone
since if we allow them to be
non-monotone and compute general
functions
over the reels they will be too powerful
and practically not interesting
so monotonicity here means that if we
increase the value of both inputs of the
gate then its output also must increase
so
if the input to a circuit is binary
and its output is also
binary we say that this circuit computes
a monotone boolean function
and the intermediate wires can take real
values that's the power of this model
and this model was thought of as an it's
the motivation was lower bounds for
proof complexity the cutting planes
proof system
and we see here an example for such a
circuit here we have eight input bits
and
except for the top gate all gates
compute just a summation over the reals
so the output of this gate can be either
zero one or two
and
we'll define
the top gate as a threshold gate
if
the sum of its input is equal or larger
than four it will output one and
otherwise it will output zero
and then this is a pretty simple circuit
actually a formula computes the
threshold function of four out of eight
and all gates uh
our monotone and the intermediate wires
carry real values
so similarly to the previous
circuit model special gates we've talked
about the formulas over slices
here we'd also expect
that this model will be more powerful
than the standard circuit model
since we have here more powerful gates
and by rosenbloom this is in fact the
case and it showed that
monotone wheel circuits can easily
realize the slice functions
and as there are double exponentially
many slice functions there it means that
they are more powerful than standard
circuits
and
his theorem says that every slice
function over l bits can be computed by
monotone real circuits of size
o l
and if we combine this theorem with the
connection we've talked about between
secret sharing schemes and
slice functions
we get as a corollary that
every function can be computed by a
monotone wheel circuit
of size three halves to the n
and this is in fact the
first
non-trivial upper bound we have for
this model that means below 2 to the n
and now back to the big picture
we want to ask whether we are done
and
the answer for upper bounds is yes we've
seen that
the recent upper bounds for secret
sharing schemes also apply to formulas
over slices and then by the
transformation of rose and bloom they
also apply to monotone wheel circuits
but we are not done yet with lower
bounds
and that is because the best lower bound
for mountain root circuits we know of is
2 to the omega n to the third
by you know northbourne gets a
generalization
of the approximation method by
rosborough to real circuits
and we want to get to a much better
lower bound of two to the omega of n
over log squared n
and we would have liked to use a lower
bound for
monotone real formulas
which achieves exactly this
by completely different techniques it's
now a generalization of the karchman
figures and lower bounds based on
communication games
done by crycek and then the lower bound
is by ghost and pitasi
but the problem is that the
transformation of rose and blooms
of rose and bloom that takes
formulas over slices outputs monotone
real circuits and not monotone will
formulate
so we cannot take this formula lower
bound and push it upwards towards our
models
and
we will try to
take anyway this lower bound and see
that it
will
indeed help us in some way
so to do that we'll need to understand
better this connection between
mountain reel circuits or formulas and
these communication games
so we'll start with a high level
description
and we do this now before defining these
games it's just to understand the world
we live in
so
the first thing to say is that modern
real circuits of size s
for a function
imply a real kw protocol for the same
function of complexity
proportional to the depth of s
and if we start with a monotone real
formula we can get a much more efficient
protocol
with complexity proportional to the
logarithm of the size of the formula
so
um by gaussian pitasi there is a
function in mountain np which requires
the real kw protocol
of length omg of
n over log squared n
and because of this transformation from
mountain range formulas to protocols we
can take this lower bound then lift it
exponentially to multiple formulas
so it is left to show for us that the
circuit generated by the rosenblum
transformation
we can also transform it to a real
protocol
with these proportions like a circuit of
size s can be transferred to a protocol
of size log s
so
of course if the circuit
is balanced
then its depth
will be low gas
but the problem is that the circuits are
not necessarily balanced then we do not
know how to balance monotone wheel
circuits or monotone with formulas the
same way that we do for
standard formulas
so we'll we need to find the way to
balance the protocol and not the formula
itself that was really high level but
then now we will define these protocols
and
things should be clearer
so we now describe real kart marvin
garzon or kw protocols and these
protocols will be held between two
parties we'll call them alice and bob
and alice holds one input of a function
f and bob holds a zero input to the same
function
the function will be monotone
and the goal of alice and bob will be to
work together and to find an index i
such that x in the eighth place is
larger than y in the eighth place
and because the function is monotone
such an index must exist and of course x
i will be equal to one and y i will be
equal to zero
so the way alice and bob approach this
task is with the help of a less or equal
oracle
it means that in each round of
communication
both of them send independently a real
number to the oracle and the oracle
responds with a bit and this bit will be
equal 1 if and only if a is smaller or
equal
to b
so we'll now see a description of this
framework an example
without a concrete function yet
we'll just say that
in round one
ali sends a message a1 a number which
only depends on f and x and bob will
send the number which only depends on f
and its input y
the oracle will respond
with a bit let's say one
and then in the next round
alice and bob will again send real
numbers to the oracle this time they
will defend
also in the previous message of the
oracle oracle will again respond and
this will go on and on
until alice and bob are ready for a
conclusion let's say for example that i
equals 7 which means that x i equals 1
and y i equals 0.
so
their challenge of course is that
the messages that they send only depend
on on their input
and they don't know the input of the
other party
and now we'll see the connection of
these circuits of these protocols to
mount unreal circuits
and
the complexity of these protocols will
be defined as the number of times the
oracle is accessed the number of rounds
and recall that we said that the
monotone real circuits
of a certain size s for a function
will imply
a real kw protocol of complexity which
depends on the depth of the circuit
so we'll now see why that is so and on
the way we'll show an example for such a
protocol on a concrete function
and the function we will work with will
be the one we've seen before which is
the four out of eight threshold function
so we would like alice and bob to
somehow use a monotone wheel circuit for
this function in order to have an
efficient real kw protocol
so let's say alice holds a one input
of f
which is x here that has four ones which
is above the threshold
and bob holds a zero input of f which
has only three ones
and their goal is to find the index in
which x equals one and y equals zero
here we only have one such index which
is a three this one
so the way they will do it is by walking
along the path
in the circuit from the root to a leaf
and each time they will both
evaluate
a sub-circuit
over their particular inputs
their goal will be to maintain an
invariant in which the sub-circuits they
work on output a larger number on
alice's input than on bob's input
so in the root
it
is clear that that's the situation
by the conditions we started with
that the entire circuit outputs one
analysis input and zero and bob's input
so
as the first step they will both
evaluate
the left sub-circuit
on their inputs
and so
the left subcircuit outputs a1 on
alice's input which will be three the
sum the sum of ones
below the subcircuit
and when bob evaluates the subcircuit on
its input the outcome b1 will be two
so they will both send
these outputs to the oracle
and the oracle here will respond with
zero because a1 is larger than d1
and because that is the situation alice
and bob
will know that this is the right
direction they want to go to
uh hoping to maintain this invariant and
reach a leaf in the end in which
the input of alice will be larger than
the input of bob
so they will repeat the step this step
and again send to the oracle the output
of the left sub-circuit on their inputs
so here
alice will send the number two and bob
will also send the number two
so this time the oracle will output one
because a2 is less or equal to
b2 and now alice and bob know that they
went in the wrong direction because the
invariant
is not maintained
so they know that they have to go to the
right sub-circuit
so again they will continue from there
and send the output on the left
sub-circuit
which here is a leaf
and now alice sends one and bob sends
zero
and the oracle will respond with
zero and
they will both know that they got to the
right index
so
in this example
by traversing the circuit we can easily
see that the complexity of the protocol
will equal the circuit depth
again the complexity of the particle
will be the number of oracle axes
that the parties alice and bob do
and
recall that we would like to get a
better connection between
the size of the circuit
and the complexity of the protocol
we'd like to know when a circuit of size
s implies a real kw protocol of
complexity which is logarithmic
in the size of the circuit
even if the circuit is not balanced
which it is in the example we've seen
so one case in which this is possible is
when the circuits we work with are
separable
and what does that mean we will say that
the
circuit is alpha k separable
if in each rooted sub graph there are k
special vertices
such that in each cloud under them
there is at most an alpha fraction of
the nodes in the circuit
and they are at most an alpha function
of nodes outside these clouds these uh
sub graphs under the k special vertices
so this is a strong global property
which applies to each root of the
subgraph in the circuit
and we would like alice and bob
to use this um
special circuit in order to
run their communication protocol more
efficiently
and they will do that by
using this property recursively
so
we like to say that um an alpha k
separable mountain wheel circuit of size
s for a function
implies a
real protocol of communication
complexity which is k times
log with the base of the inverse of
alpha to the size of s
so how do we do it
very similarly to before we would like
to
traverse the circuit from root to a leaf
but this time
instead of
sending the evaluation of a subcircuit
on one of the
children of the
nodes we are currently at
we'll send the evaluation over k
sub-circuits
so
due to the autonomicity property
we are guaranteed that in at least one
of these uh sub-circuits
the output of the sub-circuit over
alice's input will be larger than the
output of it over bob's input
so both alice and bob will send the
outputs of the circuits to the oracle
and the oracle
will
reply at least once
with a response that say says that we
can focus on this specific sub-circuit
and then alice and bob
we know that they can work only on this
sub-circuit and continue on and on until
they get to a leaf
so
in this protocol
in each phase
they
run k rounds
of the less or equal oracle
but in each such
phase the size of the
graph they work on
is reduced by a factor of alpha
so we get exactly the communication
complexity that we wanted
and so we conclude that um if we get to
a monotone real separable circuit
then we get all the properties that we
need
and
an observation
that unfortunately we don't have the
time to show we did not dwell at all
on the transformation
by rose and bloom from formulas over
slices to mountain real circuits
but it's a relatively simple
transformation
and its output is not a general monotone
real circuit but the separable one
so
[Music]
the lower bound which we will get on
separable monotone wheel circuits will
also apply to formulas over slices
and then to
secret chain schemes
with recent techniques
so now we will conclude everything
on the upper bound front
which was um
which was simpler
we realized that the upper bounds for
secret sharing schemes of three apps to
the end also apply to
the new model of formulas over slices
and then to monotone real circuits or
even formulas
and on the lower bound front
we've seen that um there is a function
which requires separable mountain rail
circuits of size two to the omega of n
over log squared of n
and due to the transformation by
rosenblum this lower bound also applies
to formulas over slices
and by our observation that in the heart
of every recent sequential schemes there
is a formula over slices with the same
size
we can get
what we wanted which is a lower bound
for these techniques
of 2 to the omega 1 over log squared of
n
so we've seen a new connection
new connections between the secret
sharing schemes and monotone complexity
theory
which continues this long line of works
and some natural open questions remained
remain
in for
each one of the three models we
discussed
so for formulas over slices
the natural questions are can we find
better upper bounds
or
improve the lower bounds to be truly
exponential now there's a gap between
the upper bound of
three halves to the n and the lower
bound which is two to the n over a poly
logarithmic factor
for monotone relay formulas
it will be interesting to see if we can
separate the monotone real formulas from
formulas over slices
as for now
the upper and the upper bounds are the
same for them
and it will also be interesting to see
if we can independently balance
monitoring real formulas and not just
communication protocols that rely on
monotone wheel formulas
and then the secret sharing front
um
there is still a big gap between upper
bounds and lower bounds
and it will be interesting to
settle it and perhaps bypass
the fos lower bounds with different
techniques
or improve the
known lower bounds
so i hope you find these ideas to be
interesting
and if you would like to see more
details i welcome you
to see the written version of this paper
and thank you very much for listening